I get started or summarizing where we
were so far so we have these we use
these bipartite expanders to construct
codes we were able to construct codes
with constant constant rate and linear
distance but unfortunately most
constructions of these expansion
bipartite expanders would also lead to
codes which are actually no not testable
in a very very strong fashion so it's
not just expansion is not going to help
us resolve this question of trying to
construct codes with constant rate
linear distance and testable with a
constant number of queries most of these
good if we're not just constant but the
linear number of queries to test so what
we're going to try to do is what is fee
so why is why do they fail to be
testable so what we try to do we look at
examples of soft codes which are
testable look into the process of
testability of these codes and see if we
can get some understanding out of them
and add this as an extra property to our
expanded goods to show if they can be
made to be tested this is right now
wishful thinking I don't know but let's
look at so let's for the remaining in
half an hour or so I'm going to look at
the example of a few codes which are
testable and try to understand why are
they tested these codes are testable but
they don't have they're they fail with
respect to the other two one of the
other two parameters either with respect
pistols or with respect to rate so what
are the codes that we know that are
testable that the sublinear number of
queries the two classic codes among the
codes which we had people think about is
one as the hugglemas code which we
mentioned this is basically the codes
which correspond to the evaluation of
all linear functions and in fact is this
is testable with three queries
before is there's another code which is
the reed-muller code which is the
evaluation of no no degree multivariate
polynomials it's not testament to the
constant number of queries but it is
it's also testable with the sublinear
number of queries so let's actually
let's look at both of these codes a
little more closely and let's look at
them right now I just defined them as we
define these two codes in the beginning
of the lecture but let's let's look at a
graphical representation of these codes
and see how it fits with the picture we
have been seeing so far the once again
let's recall how the math code is a set
of all linear it's a say evaluation of
all linear functions on the boolean
hypercube so what's the corresponding
bipartite graph representation for this
the other math code has the property
that it all these are the comes the
constraints are of the form f of X plus
F of y plus f of X plus y equals 0 so
you can come up with this sort of
bipartite graphs in which the left-hand
side has the the code word indices which
is all strings of the form all elements
of the form this should be not be n it's
actually 0 1 2 the KSR it in the figure
0 1 to the cape and the right hand side
you have all triples of the form XY x
plus y and it's connected to f of X F of
Y and f of X plus 1 so this is the
corresponding bipartite graph notice
that this graph previously we were when
we were talking about the bipartite
graph corresponding to ports the
right-hand side is always considerably
smaller than the left-hand side in fact
that was what actually gave us the rate
of the poor but here once I described
the other math code this way and I
talked about these constraints and
throwing in all the constraints these
are far more constraints than required
to express the Hamas good the other not
good it was just few of them are
sufficient to completely determine the
Hotham output most of the other
constraints in the right hand side are
actually redundant constraints but we
could draw one could one - well draw
this bipartite graph it draws it
bipartite graph between the for the code
word elements and all possible
constraints which are all these triples
of constraints so this is one natural
so is that a question or so that we will
move to this sort of we are going to
talk about testability of graphs and
we're going to test ability of certain
goods we're going to move to this this
representation of the code we're going
to have this bipartite graph for
position notice once we have this
representation we won't be able to prove
rate by showing that the right-hand side
is smaller than the left-hand side rate
will we'll have to use some other means
to prove the rate and let's assume that
we can prove that these codes do have
some sort of non non zero rate we can
prove it by some other means not by
showing not by the imbalance of it we
want to use the bipartite graph only to
prove distance and testability of the
underlying so distance will still hold
good as long as it's an expander
distance property will still you will be
able to prove distance of the poor rate
let's assume we can prove it by some
other means you know ask can we actually
prove testability of this book
so now that I've described the other
math code this way we can also describe
the reed-muller put in this similar
fashion reed-muller code you could you
can write it as and here you just want
we just make the simpler observation
that a reed-muller code is when
restricted to every line it looks like a
reed-solomon code if a reed-muller code
also has this nice bipartite graph
representation in which on the left-hand
side you have all the elements of we
have the all the code word location
which is basically all the elements of
the vector space F to the M and the
right-hand side we are going to have a
location for every line in F to the M
therefore this is basically the points
line graphs it's a point lines incidence
graph in F to BM and the right-hand side
says the local view of every right-hand
side vertex F every constraint should be
a low degree polynomial should in
particular it should be a read once it's
the restricted line it becomes a
univariate polynomial therefore the
restriction of the reed-muller code to
this particular line correspond to every
constraint on the right hand side should
be a reed-solomon code so this is sort
of the bipartite graph is L bipartite
graph representation for the reed-muller
code
once again for certain settings of M the
number of lines can be far more than the
number of points and this is not a this
is an imbalance bipartite graph the
imbalance going in the wrong direction
we won't be able to prove the rate of
the reed-muller code by looking at this
graph the rate of the reed-muller code
is put in a different fashion but we
would like to understand is looking at
this bipartite graph can one prove
testability of the reed-muller pool just
like in the previous case look at the
underlying bipartite graph and see
whether we can we drew testability of
the other mothball yes
so yesterday you said I mean there are D
randomizations in which the right hand
side can be made smaller than the left
but the rate will be the it's going to
be the same rate it's this you're just
removing a few redundant constraints
you're just reducing that's what's
happening in the video animations both
for so the cases for example what
smothers questions was you don't have to
add all triples for the case of other
mod you could just add X Y coming from
an epsilon by a set and X plus 2 the
corresponding so Phi you can just add
those triples and that will still be a
good test for this one it just removes a
few redundant constraints the rate these
things don't change the rate of the code
is unchanged in this process as long as
you're only removing redundant
constraint the four is unchanged and the
same you could do exactly the same thing
for the reed-muller so we're going to
take a slight deviation at this point
testability right now we moved from so
previously the local view we had this
bipartite graph view of every pore over
this one and we said the local you
should be such that all the elements sum
to zero but in the reed-muller case we
have slightly more general setting in
which the local does not sum to zero but
an actually element of some other poor
hood it's the element of the
reed-solomon puzzler let's actually make
this a little more formal so this will
give rise to what I call Tanner woods so
we talked about these codes from
bipartite graphs which is this object
which I talked about previously I left
you given a bipartite graph you can talk
about the natural
that arises out of it so what is it
worth stating here that every constraint
over here we are stating that it's local
you should be a member of this food even
it should be an evil member of the
should it's whatever it sees every
constraint on the right hand side should
see a member of the code even but this
of course this seems to be a completely
artificial thing why should we have work
with the code even we could have work
with any other code see not we could
have said that every constraint every
constraint on the right hand side but
the view it sees could be mmm should be
a member from C not it doesn't have to
be this even so this racist asked the
following question of Tanner graphs so
here how I'm going to construct the
sport is given a bipartite graph as
before she is LRE
and let's assume it to see labeler from
the right hand side it's regular from
the right hand side and we had given
some food see not whose block length to
see then the corresponding Tanner code
that arises out of G and C not is the
most natural extension of this in which
I'm going to put all elements X on the
left hand side so that every single
local view corresponding to the right
hand side is a member of C not now to do
this formally we have to specify a
particular ordering and the dressed
according to that ordering it should be
a member of C not I'm fudging details
over here but for every constraint we
should just buy a particular ordering of
its neighbors and according to that
ordering X restricted to envy should be
a member of C naught this is what is
called a Tanner code so you give me a
graph bipartite graph and you give me a
base code see not you can lift it up to
a larger code see on the left-hand side
this natural process these are also
called lifted ports in some contexts it
puts and what I would like to ask this
the following question are these ports
the ports so taking what I said so the
read motherhood and they're written in
this language is exactly the Tanner port
corresponding to the graph where it is a
points line graph and the smaller code
you put as the Reed Solomon puts the
reed-muller put
is that an upward chorus when you put in
the points line graph and the
reed-solomon hood and you put these two
what you get is the reed-muller hood
what I want to ask now is is there some
property of the graph G and the
underlying code C naught that makes this
corresponding object the corresponding
panel put locally testable in the case
of the Hamas code the Tanner we saw what
the graphs this and the corresponding
code see not was the even hood
what is the property that makes this
thing testable so let's actually let's
try to answer this question right we
don't yet have an answer to this
question answer this question let's go
into the proofs of why the Hazama gold
is testable so once again the math code
is this board we have this code given an
evaluation of a book of some function we
want to check if the function is linear
or is it far from linear BLR had
proposed a very natural test to check
linearity they just said pick two
elements check and look at the function
at these three points X Y and X plus y
and accept is f of X plus y equals f of
X plus F of Y and they showed this
amazing property that if the one first
thing is easy to see that if the code is
linear if the function in fact is linear
it's going to pass this test with
probability 1 and the amazing thing
about this justice if the function is
far from linear and it's actually going
to pass this test with very few very
small probability or the contrapositive
if the function if the rejection
probability of the function is very
small then the function is actually
going to be close to linear
let's just formalize whatever is no so
let's look at the rejection probability
of a function even a function let's find
out what's the probability that this
test fails this is exactly the
probability when I picked a random XY f
of X plus y is not equal to f of X plus
F of Y and look at let's look at the
distance from linearity let's look at
what's the closest linear function to
this given function and we'll look at
the distance of the function from
guarantee what we would ideally what
we'll what be a lot true is a statement
of this form if the rejection
probability is small then act then even
the distance
linearity is small there is if the test
passes with high probability then it
must be close to a to a linear function
so how does one prove this theorem so
and spend about the next five minutes or
so trying to through this theorem and in
the property while doing so we will see
that the underlying graph has some
additional properties because of which
this theorem actually goes through okay
many of you might have seen this this is
a very classic there are many of you it
has in this proof but I will sort of do
it you do do it from scratch again just
to show that this there is something out
here which says that the controlling
graph are some extra features which
makes this theorem good once again what
we want to show us be given a function s
and they know that the rejection
probability of the PMF test is very
small then we want to show that actually
this corresponding function its distance
from linearity is at most twice the
detection probability so this is what we
have and we want to prove this and how
does one typically go good you haven't
seen this is a beautiful proof to do
well and both the step first we try to
come up with the candidate close enough
close linear function we come up with
this function G which is sort of the
main so you find for every X you find
out what do the otherwise would for X
basically you look at f of X plus y
minus f of Y this is the note that Y
tells the codes that Y says X should be
if it were linear this would be exactly
f of X so G of X is the majority is the
most is the is the majority would given
by all the Y's we define this function G
of X and then the proof of we have not
was in just three steps it just shows
that this function G that we had defined
is actually close to its utmost twice
the rejection property okay that's the
first claim second claim shows that the
way we have defined G we defined G to be
the majority value of the woods with for
every X we define G to be the most is
the majority value will show that it's
not just a majority value its
an overwhelming majority value that is
if the rejection probability is not too
large in fact if it's less than
one-sixth then for every X not just most
X for every X G of X is not just the
majority but it's not just greater than
us it's actually greater than two-thirds
that is majority might you is actually
an overwhelming majority you show this
and then given this we threw the next
claim that G is actually a linear
function now once we have claims one two
and three actually just claims 1 & 2 1 &
3 will suffice to show that the F is
close to a linear function so how do we
go about proving this theorem well
actually go through each of the proofs
each of the steps of the proof
you note I move to the note or is it no
we'd like to prove the first of the
clean clean one I want to prove that
Delta F G this less than only put it
twice let's recall once again what's the
definition of G G is the most the
majority is the majority would that
every why use so the proof of this so
let's define the set pad let's define to
be those elements X such that whose
majority
it's those elements 4x4 which this
happens with probability less than hast
ever let me write it let me write this
in a slightly different fashion which f
of X is not equal to f of X plus y does
not belong to bad then in fact it is the
case the way bad is defined that G of X
is equal to f of X the majority value
agrees with f of X bad is defined as
whenever X doesn't belong to bad
G of X but this implies that basically
that Delta F of G is always less than or
equal to the fraction of bad elements
now what's the rejection probability of
F the rejection probability of F we know
is exactly probability f of X plus y not
equal to f of X plus F of y this is at
least the probability that the X I pick
X isn't bad times the probability that f
of X is not equal to f of X plus y minus
f of Y given X isn't bad this one is
equal to MU of F mu of bad and this
quantity by definition as asked is at
least half and that gives us the words
okay okay this is not that's this
disclaimer fine let's go on to the next
claim the next two claims are the
morning and we want to now show me that
if rejection probability of death is
less than 1/6 then for all X G of X
which is defined to be the majority
value is actually not just the majority
value it's an overwhelming majority back
by definition this one this expression
is at least half because it's a majority
value what I want to say it's not just
majority value it's an overwhelming
majority actually let's therefore the
proof of this claim we group given this
claim we drew the next game and then
come back to this plane you want to be
half plane
you want approving up third fling on the
show that G is me how does one through
this what do I want to show to prove
this I need to show that for all X Y I
have the property that G of X plus y
equals G X plus G but one needs to prove
this fact now let's fix any fix any XY 1
GX can be written if you know it is the
GX can be written us say FX plus C minus
FC this happens at least two-thirds of
the time bike lane 2 for a random choice
of Z this happens two-thirds of the time
Gy is FZ minus FZ plus y 2/3 of the time
this happens with probability at least
2/3 this happens with probability at
least through thirds or the choice of
set G of X plus y is f of Z plus y minus
f of X plus Z the probability at least
2/3 of the time and if you sum all the
three three equations you get zero on
the right hand side and you get the
required thing and that's something
which happens with probability strictly
greater than zero and hence it should be
if it happens this one this is there is
some Z that a witnesses this so this is
true for every single X X and one for
every x and y but empty adversarially
chose an x and y there is a set which is
going to witness the GFX plus G of Y is
G of X plus y the fact that it's an
overwhelming majority lets us prove this
so we sort us to show that you show this
sort of condition over here we are using
a and other element Z which is sort of
coding point which is sort of - coming
from the overwhelming majority to show
that G of X plus y equals G X plus Gy
yup yes I didn't catch ya sorry
Thanks so one can prove the Spencer what
what this is while proving this name
some Oh to show this worst case
condition G want to show for every X we
need a G of X plus y equals G X plus G
while we use the Z this Z which came
from claim do it show that then that is
most sense not just more six two-thirds
more than two-thirds of the said witness
the fact that G of X is equal to f of X
plus Z minus F of Z the same set
witnesses F of Z minus F of F perfect so
there will be one said that sort of
witnesses G of X plus G of y equals G of
X plus y and that's enough to conclude
this fact so what does this tell us if
you don't sort of go back to the
is it still in the note or other shifted
to these notes
back to the slides yes okay look at the
three basically said I wanted to prove
this we have this bipartite graph
between the code the 0 1 to the n + 0 1
n cross 0 1 n this was sort of defining
the constraints of 1 so even though the
actual test was between this while
proving the Hammad code was testable we
actually had this third layer which
consisted of these came up with these
heads it was talking about X Y Z so it's
this
the second layer is looking at XY x plus
y the third layer is looking at this
sort of it's going to look at X Y X plus
Z Z plus y X plus y plus Z it's going to
look at those constraints and it's a
fact that this extra layer exists is
what actually makes the local dest
ability proof goes through go through
and if you look at it now if you look at
this graph this underlying graph this
one yeah so I'm going to this graph it
is a high dimension expander the way we
defined last time that is if you look at
the edges of this this is exactly going
to be a high dimension expander so it
seems as even though the way they proof
of testability used to neither just even
the other math code was defined only
between the first two layers we use this
extra the third layer to actually prove
testability of the corresponding other
module so there was this underlying
implicit high dimensional object over
there which sort of helped us to prove
testability of the Fatima's board and
this is not just the case of the
Hadamard good instance if you also go to
the proof of the reed-muller code
there's a proof of rate model put you to
Raja and Safra in which or or even
Aurora and Sue then in which you want
this the reed-muller code is defined by
this bipartite graph between the points
graph and the lines grasp what they the
intermediate step in the proof talks
about a Plains graph it builds up this
in three layered object and uses this
three layered object to prove test
of the reed-muller pool this is one of
the proofs of way in which read mother
is the fact that reed-muller code is
good
sorry this is one of the ways in which
we know how to prune read monopolist
vegetable there are other ways in which
you don't have this third layer but it
so happens and then both these proofs
it's implicit in the proofs that you
actually even though you just had a two
layer graph and expanding graph which
define the code while proving
testability you've built this three
layer graph which was a high dimensional
expander and use this to prove
testability of the underlying object
so given this it's natural to ask if the
code that we were defining the court
that we had some Tanner code if it the
Tanner code is actually part of a high
dimension expander code I damage to
expanded does that make it easier to
prove testability in other words what
you want to ask this we had defined a
standard code this way and ask if this
graph G was actually if this two layered
graph was actually part of a three
layered object or some other object
which is that which has some high damage
to expander property then can we show
that this corresponding port is locally
testable notice that once it's part of
this larger object the thought of the
reasons for we we were able to show that
expanded codes are not testable and
there were some that's basically because
we were showing that the port had lot of
even though it violates a there are the
port there are code words which are far
from the code word but which don't
violate a lot of low weight code words
once you have this sort of three layered
object that sort of disappears so the
question is can we actually make this it
was underlined in both these proofs of
testability they seems to be an implicit
high dimensional object and is this sort
of coincidence or is it actually can one
show that if there is a high dimensional
object if the code is defined by a graph
which is part of a higher dimensional
object and one proof local testability
of the underlying code what one can show
there are some preliminary results if
the underlying high dimensional object
has extremely good agreement testing
results the way I stated
as today's lecture then one can in fact
who's such a result but of course these
are extremely strong agreement has
thicknesses so strong that we don't know
how to grow them and for all that we
know they might be false this one but
one and in fact show that if you have
such a high dimension make for an object
then there is an underlying agreement
testing theorem and one could use that
in principle to prove ocol testability
of this and sort of this has been sort
of an intriguing question for a while
and I to be I will this is what I wanted
to talk so it was asked again
we had this notion of expanding ports
expanders gave rise to ports we gave
resting fantastic properties of goods
but very same fact it was expanded
failed to be showed that you just
expansion is not sufficient to local
testability in fact expansion makes it
not locally ingestible question is most
proofs of local testability seem to
underline use this high dimensional
object and we actually make this more
formal can we actually show that if the
code if the panel code comes from an eye
dimensional object can we show that an
underlying code is no clear testable if
we interesting to show this and I think
there is a high dimensional object
lurking and the proof of testability to
answer this
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been talking about so far I've been
only talking about testability
so the question you're asking is if you
put the right hand side so large why
does the rate even survive why does the
rate completely disappear eight would
just the only code that satisfies all
these constraints could be the all zero
code word so the smaller code C not
should talk well with the graph in order
for in order with the foot to actually
for example even if you took the plane's
point graphs only if you put the
reed-solomon code word are you going to
get the read month of nice code word you
couldn't have put any other code smaller
poured over that and expected some rate
in fact most other codes you put there
the rate is going to get completely
killed and you won't get anything so
this is all true that's the other
question of are there codes for which
rate survives I don't know this so they
met so you need a seen a see not which
talks well with the geometry of the of
this object so if you've built going to
build these head actually expanders from
somehow nice number theory or something
it might be the case that there are C
knots which talk well with it and rate
is preserved just the way you should
read model codes are nice it so that's
an alternate question you also need to
write now I'm showing that if rate is
preserved an underlying code possibly is
locally testable I don't know how to
prove that rate survives at all after
this process but just like in the case
of this is all wishful thinking right
now just like in reed-muller codes the
reed-solomon code for the points line
graph the reed-solomon code is that is a
nice smaller code that talks well with
the geometry of this graph we need a C
naught which talks well with the
geometry of the corresponding high
dimension expander
[Music]
yeah that puts the focus on the other
issues firstly all the sifted quotes at
least have the reed-muller put what they
want to show is rate is even then even
more number of the rate is actually
larger than the rate they want to even
more things and that the hard work over
there is trying to show rate service I
am assuming there are codes for which
they see not speaks well and I'm hoping
that a similar proof quite sure local
Destin yeah just just asking is this
coincidence that in both these proofs
the underlying object actually is high
damage is a high damage to expander or
is that coincidence that these two local
adjustable codes between when using so
often have this high dimension expanding
object lurking underneath
okay thank you very much I thought my
visa should be there